to develop a new formulation for
sequence
comparison problem we will need to
travel to the 19th century japan
and to visit one of the yakuza run
casinos
called bakuta the acoustic crime
syndicate
had a humble beginning where the first
business operation
was running the network of frame shift
casinos
and in this casino the favorite game was
shohan
when the dealer would toss
two dice and the
visitors would bet on the outcomes
outcome being
the sum of numbers on all these two
dices
so cho means as you probably guess
even and han means odd
this is of course a fair game if the
dice are not loaded
then there is 50 50 probability of
winning
however in bakuta casinos
dealers often used biased
dice loaded dice and in this case
the outcome may be shifted towards a
casino owner or towards insider batters
also it may be fun to play chohan
in a yakuza run casino we will play an
equivalent game
where a dealer simply flips a coin and
we
bet on head or tail the challenge here
is that the dealer actually has a choice
of two coins
fair and biased for the fair coins the
probability of head
is one over two of course and for the
biased coin
the probability of head is three over
four
at this slide i showed the coins in
blue and green but in reality the coins
are completely identical
so you have no clue which coin
the dealer uses the question arises
suppose
the dealer made 100 flips and
63 of them turn on head
with each coin the dealer used fair or
biased
this question of course doesn't make
sense because
any coin fair or biased can result in 63
flips
the right question to ask is what coin
is more likely if 63 out of 100
flips resulted in hats how do we answer
this question
here's the hint 63 is a little bit
closer to 75
than 50. should we then assume
that the biased coin is more likely in
this series of flip
before we may came to this conclusion
let's try to estimate some probabilities
let's consider a sequence of n flips
denoted
x equal x one x two x n with
k hats the probability that this
sequence was generated
by the fair coin is of course 1
over 2 to the power n but the
probability
that it was generated by the biased coin
is
3 over 4 to the power k
multiplied by 1 over 4 to the power
n minus k how can we decide what coin is
more likely
of course if probability of x being
generated by fair coin
is larger than probability of x being
generated by the biased coi
that the fair coin is more likely let's
assume
let's refer to this probability as blue
probability
and green probability respectively when
we talk about probability of x generated
by
fair coin and bias and likewise
if blue probability is smaller than
green probability
then the biased coin is more likely
however when these probabilities are the
same
in equilibrium state when probably
blue probability equal to green
probability
we can compute by doing some arithmetic
that in this case
k will be equal to
a logarithm base 2 3
multiplied by n or in other word
k will be approximately equal to 0.6
multiplied by n which means that when
the number of
heads or fraction of the number of hats
is smaller than 0.632
it means that the dealer more likely to
use
their fair coin therefore our original
intuition actually was incorrect
if there are 63 heads in a series of
hundred
coin tosses then the dealer was more
likely
to use the fair coin even so 63
is closer to 75 than 250.
the dealers in traditional yakuza run
casino
were shortlist to avoid accusation and
tampering the dies because
shirtless dealer is less likely to
switch
fare dice into buyer's dice but reality
was that even shortlist there
were able to switch the dice
and we will model these situations with
two coins of the dealer slave and
instead of the previous case when dealer
run
a series of
coin flips but always using isofare
or bias coin we will assume that the
dealer now
can change the coin at any moment with
probability
0.1 so
after watching a sequence of flip can
you tell when the dealer was using the
fair coin
and when he was using the biased coin
our attempt
to read the dealer's mind brings us to
the following casino
problem given a sequence of coin flips
determine when the dealer was using the
fair coin and when
he was using the biased coin do you
think
it is a well formulated computational
problem
of course it is not because any outcome
of coin tosses
could have been generated by any
combination of
fair and biased coin and therefore
we need to grade different scenario for
example bbb
ffff bbffbb
differently depending on how likely they
are
but if we try to do this then the
question arises
how can we explore and grade
2 to the power and possible scenarios
for coin tosses here's a simple approach
to reading the dealer mind
one window at a time let's choose a
small window let's say window of five
tosses
and for each such window let's decide
which coin is more likely
to generate the outcome in this window
we already know
how to answer this question for example
for this window
hh hth there are 80
of heads therefore it's most likely
have been generated by the bias coin for
the second window
we have only 60
of heads and their forces is more likely
to be generated by the fair coin
we will actually use ratio of
blue and green probabilities and
we will decide what coin generated the
given outcome
uh by simply computing this ratio if
this ratio
is smaller than one then the bias coin
is more likely
if this ratio is higher than one then
fair coin is more likely and we will
also introduce
log odds ratio which is simply base two
logarithm
of this ratio and in this case as we
know
base two logarithm equal to the number
of tosses
minus base 2 logarithm of 3 multiplied
by the number of hats
and our decision rule for deciding
whether a given window was generated by
biased or fair coin will be simply if
logos ratio is less than zero then it is
a biased coin
if it is larger than zero then it is a
fair coin
and it is represented by this simple
rule so to continue reading the dealer
mind we will
go through the whole sequence and every
time computing with which coin is more
likely
and in the end we will classify
all these windows into being more likely
to be generated by biased or fair coin
the question however arises what are the
disadvantages
of this approach the obvious
disadvantage
of the sliding window approach is that
different windows
may classify the same flip differently
also the choice of the window left
obviously affect our conclusions
but how do you know how to choose the
window lens
and that all may be an interesting
introduction
into makeshift casino and coin flipping
but what it has to do with biology
to explain what coin flipping has to do
with biological application
we will start from a simple example of
cg islands
and then move to more complex examples
the question we will ask why are cg
dinucleotides more rare than
g-syn dinucleotides genomic sequences
well different species have widely
different gc content or percentage of g
plus c nucleotide in the genome for
example
guerrilla and human have gc content
46 percent why platypus has gc content
58 which means that on average if the
distribution was uniform you would
expect
that both nucleotide g and c appear in
the genome of this probability
in human genome with probability of 23
percent
and therefore you would expect that each
of dinucleotides cc
cg gc and g append the genome of this
frequency 5.29 percent
but the reality is that the frequency of
cg
in the human genome is five times
smaller
why methylation is a dna modification
that
adds a metal ch3 group
to the citizen nucleotide and it often
happens
within a c in c g
dinucleotide the resulting ventilated
citizen
has the tendency to daminate into timing
and as a result of methylation cg
is the least frequent dinucleotide in
many
genomes however methylation is often
suppressed
in the areas around genes called cg
island where cg appears frequently
for this toy example this would be a cj
island
and the question arised that how
suppose you want to find genes how would
you search for cj islands as a
prerequisite
for finding genes well if we would use
the same paradigm of logos ratio and
simply classify cg island as more likely
in the area where this logo its register
is less than zero
and uh non-sigil island more likely in
the area where
logos asia is larger than zero then
we will arrive to a classification
algorithm for cj islands however
there are a few issues as before
different windows may classify the same
position in the genome differently
it is not clear how to choose the length
of the window to construct cg island
and very importantly it is not clear
whether we should use the
same length of windows for different
regions of the gem and in the next
section i will describe the notion of
hidden marker model
that provides a new better paradigm for
problems like
finding cg islands and many many other
problems in bioinformatics